l'épiphanie c'est le jour où les rois
mages arrivent à Bethléem pour adorer
l'enfant nouveau-né le roi des Juifs
c'est une fête importante dans la dans
la liturgie chrétienne c'est une des
fêtes qui suivent la naissance du Christ
en ce dimanche 6 janvier les fidèles
chrétiens de l'église Saint-Louis de
Versailles était venu nombreux célébrer
cette fête qui marque la manifestation
du Christ dans le monde alors cette fête
se traduit aujourd'hui d'abord de
manière de manière spectaculaire dans
l'orthodoxie pour l'orthodoxie les
glisseurs de l'Église catholique la fête
de l'Épiphanie et la grande fête de la
Nativité parce que l'événement de la
Nativité ce n'est pas que ce n'est pas
pour eux d'abord que
Dieu vienne dans la chair en
Jésus-Christ mais d'abord qu'il soit
révélé à toutes les nations pour le
catholicisme l'épiphanies revêt la même
signification avec une messe
particulière on marque la liturgie en
comme un jour de fête c'est-à-dire avec
les ornements blancs des prêtres ou de
l'évêque qui célèbre tout à l'heure ce
qui marque surtout la fête ce sont les
textes que nous choisissons trois textes
l'Évangile le Livre d'Isaïe et l'épître
Éphésiens qui s'ajoutent aux prières
lues tout au long de la messe et si
cette messe célébrait l’épiphanie elle
marquait également la veille de la
rentrée un temps toujours plein de
ferveur pour les fidèles de l'église
Saint-Louis venu apporter leur message
oh un message qui est pas mal dans son
nom celui de la paix tout simplement